[موسيقى]
لقاء رجل ضد القتل مع رجل
تحدثنا حقًا عن جلب
الموارد ، لقد تحدثنا عن
الأمهات أمهات أبناء القتل الذين تعرفهم
ومواقف مختلفة في
الشوارع
لأنه من الصعب أخذ شيء من
شخص ما
إذا لم تفعل ذلك  لديك شيء
لاستبداله ، فكيف يمكنني إخبارك بالتوقف عن بيع
المخدرات
إذا كان لديك شيء لوضع بعض المال
في جيبه كيف يمكننا إخبارهم
أننا لا نريدك أن
تتعامل مع العنف ، كما تعلم إذا لم نكن نريد
كن من
سيتأكد من أنه يمكنهم الحصول على بعض
الحماية
[موسيقى] ،
فإن أفضل عمل هو العمل الذي تحب
القيام به ما تشعر به هو أنه
يمكنك الاستيقاظ كل يوم والذهاب إلى هناك
بابتسامة على وجهك ، وأعتقد أنه يجب عليك  أفعل
ذلك ،
أريد أن أكون قادرًا على الاستيقاظ وأكون مثل
نعم ، سأذهب إلى العمل
الآن عندما تعمل في وظيفة
حيث تتعامل مع سلوك شخص ما
طوال اليوم ،
ثم ينتزعك الآن أنت
أنت '  إعادة منحهم الموقف
لأنهم يعطونك الموقف  لكن عندما
يكونون سعداء ،
تكون حياة سعيدة ، زوجة سعيدة ،
نفس الشيء هو عميل سعيد ،
عمل سعيد سعيد ، سأذهب إلى هذه
المقابلة اليوم
في سوق طعام ألدي ، لدي سيرتي الذاتية
وأنا آمل أن أفعل ذلك  أن أكون قادرًا على أن أكون
ناجحًا في هذه
المقابلة اليوم ، حيث سأكون قادرًا على
جني أموال
جيدة واكتساب مسؤوليات جديدة في الحياة
لنفسي من
أجل مستقبلي ،
حسنًا يا سيدي ، هل لديك
طلب تم ملؤه أعتقد أولاً
أنني أفعل ولكنه في  المتجر الآخر ،
هل تتطلع إلى
العمل هنا في منطقة التلال الشمالية ،
أيهما لأنني يمكنني
ركوب حافلة
إذا كنت ترغب في ملء طلب هنا ،
يمكنك القيام بذلك أيضًا لأنني أعتقد
أن هذا
مدير منطقة مختلف
هناك تمامًا  متروك لك ، لذا فأنت
مرحب بك أكثر من شخص ما هنا ،
ولكن إذا كان لديك أي أسئلة حسنًا ،
فقد قالوا إنني
سأتلقى مكالمة مرة أخرى
للمقابلة التي أتيت إليها
اليوم وآمل أن يأخذوني
فقط دعكم تعرفون  مع هذا أه أحب
عائلتي هنا
أنت تعرف مفتاح الأخ أنت تعرف أنه
شخص ما
هذا الأخ الصغير هنا كان بعيدًا
عن السلسلة ، لقد
غير الله حياته هذا هو برندان
هذا هو ابني الإلهي
الجنس المال قتل الدم لقد بدأت
العمل معه هو
غيّر حياته وهؤلاء
إخوة أثق في نوع الأشياء التي
كنا نقوم بها في
محاولة لزعزعة قصصنا
ومشاركتها حياتنا مع الناس وإعلام
الناس بوجود أخطاء في الماضي
لإخبار الناس أن بإمكان الناس
تغيير الوضع الحالي لا  لا يجب أن
تكون وجهتك النهائية ،
أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة لأكون قادرًا على
الوقوف هنا
ويعرف أيضًا باسم تيد مجنون ، لكن يمكنني أيضًا الوقوف هنا
حيث أن دكتور تيد
شخص ما سيواصل
القتال
ضد الظلم يواصل القتال كما
تعلم ضد الطريقة التي يعرفها شبابنا
الرجال يذهبون إلى السجن بالطريقة التي يتعرضون بها
لإطلاق النار عليهم
بالطريقة التي يفقدون بها
حياتهم في الشوارع
[موسيقى]
هذه المقصات هنا هي
مقصات محركات مختلفة  شفرات
بمستويات مختلفة ،
كل شفرة تدخل في بعضها البعض مثل
هذا واحد ونصف
إذا قمت بقصها بهذه الطريقة ، فستكون
مكافئة
لـ 1 أ مع الحبوب ، أهم
شيء في كونك حلاقًا
هو معرفة ما يمكن أن تفعله أدواتك
عند قص
الشعر ، يجب أن يكون كل شيء بالزي الموحد ، يجب أن يكون كل شيء
حتى متوسط الوقت لقص الشعر الجيد هو
0 دقيقة ، كل حلاق لديه تق
ية مختلفة عن
ما أكون من فيلادلفيا إذ
كنت تتعارض مع الاتجاه إذا انتهكت ذلك لأ
ه يصدم  شعر كيف تعلمت
التجربة والخطأ في العبث بالكثير من
الرؤوس هذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة التي تجعلك جيدًا
كحلاق يجب أن تفسد
حتى تقابل مدينة بربرية لم تفسد أبدًا ،
إنه
يكذب وتحصل على مدرسين جيدين لديّ واحد ، نعم
كان لدي مرشد لأنه عندما كنت
محبوسًا كان هناك مجموعة من الشباب
وكانوا جيدين حقًا
وكانوا يتمتعون بسرعة جيدة
وكنا نتقاضى أجورًا
للسجائر وقال شريف ، هل تريد أن تكون
حلاقًا جيدًا
أم تفعل فقط  تريد صنع السجائر  قال si ،
أريد أن أكون حلاقًا جيدًا
، قال حسنًا ، لا تقص
الشعر من أجل
السجائر وأقول ما تقصده قال لا
تقطع هنا لأن السجائر تركز على
أن تكون حلاقًا جيدًا ،
لذلك هذا  ما فعلته
[موسيقى]
كان يريد التحدث إليكم حول هذه
الحياة الواقعية في الشارع ، أوه نعم قصتي يا
رجل قصير ، من الصعب هنا هذه
ليست لعبة نخرجها هنا كل يوم
نخسر إخواننا كل يوم شخص
نشأت معه  ذهب اليوم التالي هنا
وما زلنا هنا يجب أن نحقق ذلك ،
يجب أن نفعل ما يجب أن
نفعله وأنا بالخارج كل يوم ، وليس
باختيار ، أتمنى أن أتمكن من الخروج من
هنا ولكن
niggas فقط  يجب أن نلتقي معًا ،
أعذر لغتي ، لكن علينا أن نجتمع
معًا بخلاف
أنه سيزداد سوءًا وأسوأ ،
كنت أحد الأشخاص الأصغر سنًا عندما
كان يكتب المسلسل ، وكان السلك
ليل ملفين هو عرابي ، كنت
هنا
جزءًا من المشكلة.  انتهى به الأمر في الواقع
رجل يطلب من الله أن يعطيني فرصة ثانية
في ميتشل ج
مباني منزلنا قبل 10 دقائق من
الحكم عليّ بالسجن 15 عامًا ، وأعطاني الله
معجزة ومنذ ذلك الحين رجل أحاول
العمل مع الإخوة في محاولة لمعرفة
كيف يمكنني
المساعدة إذا لم يحصل الناس على  قصة
أنهم لا يعرفون أن هذا النوع من الأشياء
يحدث بشكل صحيح ، فأنت تعلم
ما أقوله كأن لا أحد لا يعرف
أن لديك طفلين قاب
قوسين أو أدنى ، كل ما حصلوا عليه هو
المعكرونة والنودلز في الخطاف
الذي لا يفعلونه  لا أعلم أنه
سيتعين عليك إنجاب أطفال ربما في الخارج
يحاولون الحصول على المعكرونة
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] في كثير من الأحيان يجنون الكثير من
الرجال الذين يتناولون الطعام على
كرة تعرج في جيبهم مثل
لم أرَ شخصًا لديه عقد بقيمة خمسة عشر
ألف دولار هنا ،
أعتقد أنه قد انخفض أكثر من 50
حجة niggas 50 مناقشة 20
حجة تعرف أي رجل أقدره حتى لو
استغرقت وقتًا لقول شيئًا ما
لأنك تعلم أن
أول شيء هو  شخص ما يرى أنك تعرف
الكاميرا أولاً ، يعتقد أحدهم أن الوظيفة  القمل
آخر شيء سأقوله بشكل حقيقي على
الكاميرا إذا كان هناك شخص ما يشعر
وكأنك تقوم بعمل سيء ،
أشعر وكأنك يا رجل
، لا شيء مثل ما يشبه البرنامج التلفزيوني
ثلاث مرات ،
إنه أسوأ بكثير مما يعتقده الناس
غابة
[موسيقى]
كنت أعمل في الواقع مع أشخاص
يعانون من
إعاقات mhmr وقد طُردت من هذه الوظيفة وكنت
جالسًا لمدة شهرين تقريبًا
أتساءل وكوني ساعي البريد كان
دائمًا شيئًا اعتقدت أنه
سيكون عملًا رائعًا بالنسبة لي  شيء
يناسبني ولكن إذا كان بإمكاني أن أقول
ما إذا كنت قادرًا على القيام بذلك مرة أخرى وإذا
كنت أكثر ذكاءً قليلاً ،
كنت سأكون متخصصًا في
علم النفس وقاصرًا في علم الاجتماع ،
أعتقد أنك تعلم أنه سيتوافق
بشكل جيد مع
مع كل شيء ولكن في الواقع
تخصص علم اجتماع وكونك ساعي بريد ،
فهذا نوع من العمل مع هذا
لأنني أعمل مع المجتمع طوال الوقت
[الموسيقى]
عليك أن تعمل مثل العبد
كلما بدأت لأول مرة ،
أعتبر أنك بدوام جزئي ولكن
انت مو  إعادة أو أقل مجرد عبد عامل وسيجعلونك
تعمل لساعات فقط بالإضافة إلى ساعات العمل ، وإذا كان
بإمكانك البقاء على قيد الحياة أثناء القيام بذلك
والعمل طوال اليوم وعدم معرفة
إلى أين أذهب ،
فأنا آسف لدي حزمة
موجودة لدي  الشاحنة التي يجب أن
أقودها من أجلك ، شكرًا لك ، حسنًا ، لقد قابلت جميع
أنواع الأشخاص ،
كل الأنواع التي تود أن تعتقد
أنها عنصرية
لأنك سترى أشخاصًا يخرجون من سياراتهم
وسوف يرونك قادمًا وهم "  سوف
يتأذون ويبدو أنهم سوف
يسرعون ويصطدمون بالمنزل
كما لو أنهم لا يريدون ذلك لأنهم لا يريدون
التحدث معك أو الحصول على بريدك أو
أي شيء من هذا القبيل
عندما لا يكون لديك وظيفة تحاول ذلك
العثور على وظيفة هو وظيفة
يمكن أن يشعر بها بعض الناس بالإحباط
من الحصول على وظيفة معينة
لأنهم لا يريدون أخذ
شاشات تعاطي المخدرات أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل
يصعب العثور على وظيفة عندما لا
يكون لديك واحدة
[موسيقى]
السبب في أنني أحاول تبديل
الوظيفة الآن هو أنني أعلم أنه يمكنني العمل
في الوظيفة التي كنت
فيها  أصبح الأمر أكثر صعوبة الآن لأنهم حكموا
علي بالطريقة التي أحب بها
استعادة بشرتي بشكل أساسي يتحدث لوني من
قبل بكلماتي عن
الأشياء التي يبحثون عنها في مقابلة عمل
عندما تذهب إلى مقابلة مع سائق ،
فهم يبحثون عنك
لارتداء ملابس جميلة
ما لا يدركون أنه لا
يريد الجميع أن يرتدي ملابس مثل أن لكل شخص
تفضيلًا مختلفًا حول طريقة لباسه ،
كما تعلم ، هناك بعض
الأشخاص الأكثر استرخاءً ويفضلون ارتداء
بنطلونات رياضية وأحذية
وقميص فقط وربما  قبعة فوق
رؤوسهم للحصول على أي قصة شعر أو
إذا لم يقوموا بقص شعرهم ، فهم
أكثر قلقًا بشأن استيقاظهم
من فراشهم
والاستعداد لليوم الذي
نهض فيه هذا الشخص من سريره وجاء
إليك للتو  مما يعني أنه من الواضح أن لديهم
أفكارًا جيدة إذا جلست هنا يا رفاق
وأخبروني أنك لن تصل أبدًا إلى
أي شيء في النهاية ،
سأعتقد أنه أكثر من ذلك أن السود يستمعون
إلى الأشخاص البيض لأن هذا ما
كان علينا أن نفعله بالكامل  الحياة تعرف ما
أعنيه أنه
يتعين عليهم فعل ذلك لفترة طويلة
لدرجة أنهم الآن بعد أن خرجوا منها لا
يعرفون كيف يتصرفون
[موسيقى]
ظلوا يسمعون أن
السود يفعلون ذلك
يجب أن يكون السود على هذا النحو من قبل الناس بهذه
الطريقة ، لذا فهم الآن على ما يرام ، لن
أكون على ما يرام أبدًا ،
ثم سأجلس هنا وأبيع المخدرات ،
ثم
أخبرني بالفعل أنك  لن
أساعدني في الوصول إلى هناك ، ولهذا السبب
هم وكأنهم يستسلمون بسهولة ، لقد
تعلمت عندما كنت محبوسًا في
السجن ، كنت في السجن ، نعم بسبب أي
عمل شخصي لم أكن أتحدث عنه ببضع
كلمات  النشاط
مجرد قصة صغيرة ، حسنًا ، لقد
قمت ببيع المخدرات ، لماذا لأن البيئة التي عشت فيها ، نشأت في شوارع فيلادلفيا حتى تعرف أن بيع المخدرات والحصول على
النساء هو الشيء الذي
بعته من 15 حتى ذهبت إلى
السجن
7 16. كل هذا الرجل أعطاه 21 عامًا
كنت مدمنًا على أسلوب الحياة إذا كان بإمكاني
ألف دولار في ثلاث ساعات بينما
أذهب إلى العمل وأدرك أن
لديّ حرفة وأنا جيد في ذلك ، لذا كل ما
فعلته هو نقل طاقة الشارع
حتى
باربرا
ما أصنعه الآن هو
حلاق  خمسة ستة آلاف في الشهر في
بعض الأحيان عندما تبدأ في العمل
كتاجر مخدرات ، يجب أن تقضي 24 ساعة
في الشارع
عندما تبدأ كحلاق ، يجب
أن تمنح حوالي 16 ساعة ،
نعم إنه لأمر أكثر خطورة أن تكون في
الشوارع لماذا لا يزال الناس يقيمون  هناك
لأن هذا ما يحلو لهم تمامًا
في روسيا ، لديك الغوغاء الروس ،
هذا ما يحلو لهم ، نحن
لن نذهب إلى معطف السكر مثل كل
شيء خوخي ،
بل ما يعجبهم هذه هي الحياة التي
اختاروا أن يعيشوها
فقط هم من يمكنهم التغيير  عقلهم
مثلما استيقظت ذات يوم وقلت إنني
لن أعود إلى السجن ، يمكنهم أن يفعلوا نفس
الشيء ، كل شخص يحصل على نفس الـ 24
ساعة وهذا ما تريد أن تفعله خلال
24 ساعة
[الموسيقى]
تمسك بأكلك  حصلت على وظيفة
تعرف ما أقوله  لكنك تريدني
أن أتوقف عن فعل ما أفعله بشكل
صحيح والحصول على الورق ، لكنك لن
تطعمني أنت لن تطعم
عائلتي كما لو
كنت تعرف ما أقول إنه مثل
العودة إلى المنزل من أكثر إلى  السجن
عندما تعتقد أنك
ستتغير بشكل صحيح ، ولكن إذا
أتيت من السجن إلى السجن ، فارجع مباشرة إلى
نفس الحي الذي يعيش فيه
الرجل في غضون أسبوع ،
فستعود إلى هناك إذا عدت إلى المنزل ،
اذهب إلى مكان آخر فقط
جرب الكثير منا لا نعرف حتى أنه لم ينته بعد ولكن
بخلاف هذه
الموسيقى ، نعم ، نعم ، لماذا تبصق
أنت تبصق ، دعني أسمع شيئًا سريعًا حقًا ،
نعم ، دعني أسمع شيئًا
دعني أجعلني أعرف أنه
صخب الحياة الصعبة  كل ما أعرفه
هو صراع لا يوجد لديه مال ، كل ما كنت أعرفه
هو أن
الأم الصاخبة قد جعلتني أشعر وكأنهم
يفهمني الناس ، ولا أخبرهم
بأي شيء
يلعب الرهان لأن هؤلاء النيجات يخافون ،
أنا أطلق النار على الزنجي الأول اللعنة
كنت
أخت المناقشة شابة وأنا دائمًا
أجذب السارق الذي لا يمكنك أخذه  لا شيء
يسرق الحياة ستفقد حياتك ، أعلم
أنها أوقات عصيبة أحاول أن أستعد
للحياة العقلية في هذا العالم البارد لتمزيقك من
العمل الشاق جسديًا يؤتي ثماره ، لكن
المستقبل لا يعد أبدًا
باللون الأسود على الجريمة السوداء ولكننا
أنجزناه مثل
المدارس الأقل من السجون
قد تساعد الحكومة الناس ، لكنه لا
يفعل شيئًا سيئًا بالنسبة لي إذا كان الأمر متروكًا لهم ، فإن
الكثير من الأرواح ستكون مجرد تاريخ ،
ببساطة ، استمر في الانتقال إلى نهايتي
الرجل الذكي الذي هو الأطول الذي
ألعب فيه  الكفاءة
التي تعرفها عن تاريخي الأوقات الصعبة ،
حرفيًا ، أحاول أن أجعل صناعة لقد
سئمت من الشعور بالبؤس ،
هذا حي خطير في
الواقع ، هذه هي سنتي الثالثة الكاملة فقط
من العمل في هذه الوظيفة في هذا الحي ،
لقد سمعت طلقات نارية أثناء  كنت أسير
في الشوارع حتى فتاة
تعرضت للاعتداء مرة واحدة من قبل رجل
وبعض الأشياء من نوع العنف المنزلي
يحصل الناس على جميع أنواع الرسائل
وعادة ما يكون ما
يتكون منه معظم بريدنا هو بريد غير
هام  أنه لا يُفترض
بنا حقًا أن نقول لأن هذا يبقينا
في الأساس بوظيفة
يمكن أن يقترب منك بعض الأشخاص
ربما لتقديم حزمة مثل عبوة دواء
أو شيء من هذا القبيل
وهو أمر يثير استياءنا بالتأكيد
لأننا نفعل
هذا ليس بالأمر الجيد  الشيء هناك يقدمون
لك بعض المال وأنت تعلم
حاول إقناعك بتسليم طرد
ثم الشيء التالي الذي تعرف
أنك تفعله مرة واحدة ثم يريدون
منك أن تفعل ذلك مرارًا وتكرارًا ومرة أخرى لا
ي الواقع تم الاتصال بي هن
في هذا الشارع من قبل شخص ما
مثل الجلوس هناك كما لو كان يريد أن
يخبرني عن أسعار الأدوية وأشياء من
هذا القبيل وأنا مثل أه
لا أعرف أي شيء عنها ،
فأنا لا أحبه ، فأنا لا أفعل ذلك.
لنغوص في أي شيء من هذا القبيل ،
هذا ليس فنجان الشاي الخاص بي ، وأشياء
رأيي الشخصي في ذلك هو أنك
تعرف لكل شخص ، كل شخص لديه
مستوى الراحة الخاص به لما يشعر
أنه يريد القيام به أو
أي شيء آخر لا أفعله بالتأكيد.  ر ينظر
إلى أسفل على أي  الجسد
الذي يبيع المخدرات أو أي شيء لأنه
في الواقع
لديهم قلب أكبر لفعل ذلك أكثر
مما أفعله لقد نشأت بالفعل مع
والد زوجي
الذي كان يتعاطى المخدرات لفترة من الوقت عندما كنت
طفلاً وهو  هل
كان كما لو كان يأتي إلى غرفتي
كلما كنت أنام ،
كان يسرق أموالي ليأخذ
دراجتي ويبيعها ذات
مرة يبيع حذائه من قدميه
مرة واحدة كل هذا باسم الحصول على
المخدرات
كل ذلك  يعتمد على تفضيلات الأشخاص ،
هناك أشخاص في الواقع يبيعون
المخدرات ولا يزالون يشغلون وظيفة ثابتة
في نفس الوقت
الذي تعرف فيه أن الأمر كله يعتمد على حالة
الشخص وكيف يريدون التعامل مع الأشياء
التي تعرفها مثل  بيع
المخدرات ولديك وظيفة ثابتة علاوة
على ذلك ، فإن المهمة الثابتة هي
أساسًا ما هو الحساب
الذي تفعله ، وتعلم
أنه مثل التستر على الأوساخ التي
تقوم بها بالفعل تحت
مخدرات [الموسيقى]  دائما كل شيء عن
المال دائما عن مون  ey
لم يكن أبدًا خياري كما
قلت أنا لا أملك قلبًا
لفعل ذلك
ولا أرى نفسي ينتهي به المطاف في السجن
لمجرد ربح سريع
إذا لم يكن لديك أي فكرة
عملية نحو المستقبل ،
فأنت حقًا لا تصل إلى أي مكان في
الحياة ، هكذا أنظر إليها
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] أجلس وأتذكر بعض
الأيام الخوالي في أعماق الهاوية  الكثير
من الطرق المجنونة التي تراها لم أكن معتادًا على
أن أكون الحذاء الجيد الذي
كنت أعمل به مع طاقمي ولكن الآن أنا
بوو جديد ولكن عندما تفكر في الأمر
لم نتحدث عنه
أنا وطاقمي مرة أخرى  ثم كنا ننتقل إلى
هذا الحد ولا أعرف حقًا
كيف وصلت إلى هذا الحد عندما
أجلس وأعتقد أنه غريب
ولكن أعتقد أن الرب كان
يفحصني في الواقع ، لابد أن الرب
كان يباركني للسماح لهؤلاء  الرصاص
ليحيط بي
حتى يتمكن هؤلاء من رؤية يوم آخر ، لذا
فإن
وظيفتي الآن هي العودة إلى المجتمع ،
وكأنني أحظى بحصانة دبلوماسية في
هذا العالم الشرير  لا يمكنهم فعل أي شيء
لي في هرمجدون ، فأنت تعرف جيدًا
ما الذي سيصبح قريبًا
[موسيقى]
يجب أن يكون هذا مناسبًا تمامًا ،
هل لديك مثل أي
مناصب أمنية مفتوحة في
الواقع ليس في هذا المبنى ولكن إذا كنت
ترغب في تطبيق عالمي عبر الإنترنت ،
فأنا أحاول ذلك  أولاً ، شارك شهادتي
الخاصة لأنني كنت أعرف أنني كنت مشكلة
بالنسبة لي ،
فأنا أعرف ما الذي يجب أن أنظر إليه في
التهم
التي تعرفها عن الابتزاز ، أنت تعرف
مسدس بطارية الاعتداء ، لكنني أيضًا في
نفس الموقف حيث يمكنني المشاركة
معهم نعم ولديّ درجة البكالوريوس الآن حصلت
على درجة الماجستير الخاصة بي ،
وبدأت في السكن الانتقالي لأعضاء العصابات ،
وبدأت في
برنامج العيش المستقل للشباب المسنين خارج
رعاية التبني ، وبدأت في تسجيل استوديو
للشباب وبدأت في التجول في جميع أنحاء البلاد
لمساعدة  الشباب الذين
لا يولدون في الأصل ويموتون نسخة لا
تكون
مملًا شيئًا خاصًا وبعد ذلك
تغوص في محاولة لتكون
مثل أي شخص آخر ،
هؤلاء الإخوة هم في الواقع من
الخارج.  أنت تعلم وجميعًا معًا ،
نعم ، نعم ، نعم ، مثل بعضهم في
الواقع
من موسكو ، نعم ، نعم ، أعلم أن هذا
مجنون ،
أراك في بالتيمور ، لقد
أخبرتك أنك في بالتيمور ، يمكنك الحصول على أفضل ما في
بالتيمور هنا
يمكن للناس التغيير ، وإذا  أنت
، وإذا كنت تريد حقًا رؤية
أحدهم ، فأنت تنظر إليهم ، شخصًا
هدد شخصًا ما ركل
شخصًا في الداخل ، شخصًا قام ببعض
الأشياء التي لست فخوراً بها
ولكني الآن وقد تمت دعوتي إلى  اذهب
إلى أماكن مثل البيت الأبيض أو
الكونجرس ،
لقد تمت دعوتي للذهاب إلى أماكن
لن تفكر فيها أبدًا ،
لذلك كان لدي مدير وضع رهانًا
لن أتمكن من الوصول إلى
21 مستشارًا قال إنه لا ينبغي أن
أحاول ذلك  اذهب إلى الكلية
ومحامي الولاية الذي قال
إنه لا ينبغي السماح لهذا الشاب
بالعودة إلى
المجتمع وأنا نفس الشخص الذي حصل
على جائزة الدكتور مارتن لوثر كينغ الوطنية ،
إنه مجرد جنون تقريبًا لذا يجب أن
أشارك بعضًا من  قصتي
حتى يروا أنها تشان  ce
عن
التغيير وهذا حقًا ما أنا
بصدد التغيير ،
لقد رفضوني مرة أخرى
[ضحك]
أخبرني أنه يجب عليّ الطيران عبر الإنترنت ،
فالروحانية أولاً هي المادية الثانية
ولكن
الثروة مهمة جدًا
ولكن المهم هو ما
يفكر فيه الفرد
لأنفسهم في الواقع ، يقول الكتاب المقدس
كما يعتقد الرجل في قلبه ،
فهل هو الآن تمييز ، فهذا تمييز
مختلف
هو فعل ، إنه شيء
يفعله الفرد
ضد شخص ما لأنه قد
لا يعجبه
جيدًا ويقولون إنه غير قانوني إنه
يزعجني
أنا لا  أريد أن أستمر في القيام بذلك المشي
في تلك الأماكن ،
ليس لدي أي نقود في جيبي ، لا
أحد يهتم بي ،
الحياة أكثر من اللازم الآن لهذا ،
أريد فقط العودة إلى المنزل وكأنني
مستاء  كأنني لا أستطيع أن أفعل هذا
ولكني أحاول كل يوم فقط لأنه
يجعلني أشعر بالسعادة لأن أقوم وأبتسم
أو أن أقوم وأحاول أن أفعل شيئًا
لتحسين حياتي ،
ما رأيك بي بسبب
لون بشرتي الذي يناسبني  مشكلة
بخير لأننا  استخدم أنا أعرف من أنا
رجل ينظر إلى المظهر الخارجي ولكن
الله دائمًا ما ينظر إلى القلب
لا يمكنني الذهاب بعد الآن ، لا يمكنني دائمًا التفكير في
أن
الأمور ستكون جيدة على
الرغم من أنني أعتقد أنه لا يوجد شيء معها في
الأساس  كأنني أشعر أنه ليس
هناك شيء جيد يأتي
مثل الحياة اليومية التي تعيش هنا ،
فهم لا يجعلون من السهل على
رجل أسود
أن يفعل أي شيء كنت أحاول أن
أجعله أسهل على نفسي في كل مرة أحاول أن
أكون  أسهل بالنسبة
لي ، أي شخص يريد أن يجعل الأمر أكثر صعوبة بالنسبة لي ،
فأنت تريد مني التقديم عبر الإنترنت في
كل شيء لا يمكنني الدخول فيه
بسيرة ذاتية وألبس
لطيفًا بعد الآن ، أعني فرصة أخرى
يمنحني إياها شخص ما
لقد أكدت نفسي ولكن يمكنني ذلك  لا أفعل
أي شيء
إذا لم يساعدني أحد على القيام بذلك ، يمكنني فقط أن
أساعد نفسي
ولكني أعمل على مساعدة نفسي
بالأدوات التي أمتلكها ولا يكفي
ذلك بشكل واضح للآخرين ، لذا
يصعب عليك الوصول إليها بالفعل
حيث تريد أن تكون لأن
أمامك الكثير من العقبات
[موسيقى]
يا